[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
rebounded by rddr Cano and finished
final of eternity
[Applause]
what a great dunk by karl-anthony towns
amazing
[Music]
that's why these Milwaukee fans is so
high because they have an MVP candidate
that loves giving the people what they
want and that should dump since I'd take
away by the Lakers this jaw
Benten Showtime Lakers
that was no
[Applause]
[Music]
don't have that pass to make that catch
and throw it down like that
[Applause]
I mean this is like nerf hoop slightly
stop bowler down in the basement you're
a kid you put it on a five-foot hoop but
you go up and you see what you can do
Michels doing it on a ten-foot
[Music]
this
Oh Derrick Favors career comes from
[Applause]
new facial that's riding it up and
riding it down with a purpose
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's got the lead
Dutch drums - l'chaim don't sleep
belukha now I'm pressing it on you I am
throwing it down play of the day dear
sir
we had to throw that in BAM throws it a
little wide and yes to crank back watch
how he doesn't dunk it he's throwing it
in he just spiked that ball in what up
it's a boy Adam left coach you like that
content I know you like that content hit
subscribe for more of it from Bleacher
Report